hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
another one of the social virtues which
aristotle talks about is what he calls
friendliness
and he wants to distinguish this from
friendship
per se philia and
sometimes aristotle is a little
inconsistent in his greek terminology
from from the nickel mccain ethics the
udamian ethnics to the politics to the
to the rhetoric but but in general he
distinguishes between
friendship and this this condition of
friendliness and then the emotion
involved in being friendly towards
somebody
and this is a state of character
and it's a mean position meaning that
it is in between two vices
there's a vice of excess and divisive
deficiency
too much too little and
what constitutes being a friendly
or a medical or
somebody with good social skills type of
person
for aristotle it really has to do with
giving pleasure and pain to other people
and in general if we have the chance to
give them pleasure by engaging
in social activities with them aristotle
thinks we ought to do that
that there's something wrong with a
person who doesn't want to do that or
sort of perversely wants to give pain to
other people
now should we go along with everything
no
so the person who's friendly they go
along with they join in
they approve the right things
they don't approve everything
as a matter of fact they will have
certain limits where they will refuse or
criticize
the wrong things so if i suggest hey
let's go shoplifting
a person who's being friendly doesn't
say to me yeah that's a great idea
they say i think it's a bad idea let's
not do that
and then if i keep pushing they'll
eventually say hey no i'm not i'm not
going along with you as a matter of fact
i don't think i want to
talk to you after this that would be an
example of what aristotle
now on the other hand if i invite
somebody to a party and it's you know
a normal kind of party it's not you know
something really weird
or off the wall like uh you know
say a snuff party or something like that
then
they say yeah let's let's let's go let
me check my calendar let me see if i can
make this
they won't refuse to engage in things
now if you say
hey i want to go to this rave and while
people are
dancing around i want to punch a lot of
people in the face then they're going to
say
there's something wrong with you that's
not what you should do at a party
you know we could make up all sorts of
examples like this
and so it has to do with what sort of
activities you're willing to
to engage in are they are they the right
kind of activities or the wrong kind of
activities and somebody might say
oh well that's all very subjective this
is a common
objection that's always made and it is
difficult sometimes to determine exactly
where the boundary lines
uh fall but if you're looking at things
from an aristotelian perspective
that's not the case it's not all up for
grabs it's not all just a matter of
opinion
there are some considerations that we
ought to be guided by
honor and usefulness or the opposite of
these
dishonor shamefulness and
harm if something is going to actually
be harmful
to a friend whether in the short term
or in the long term if it's damaging to
them
then you're not actually being a friend
by saying yeah yeah man i think you
ought to do that that's a great idea
you're probably setting them up for for
harm and that's being a bad friend
that's actually being over here on this
side on the other hand if you know if
your friend is suggesting something
that's good for them even if it's not
something that you perhaps
want to do like let's say they decide
you have a friend that you're always
going out to the bars with and they say
you know i gotta curtail this activity
it's costing me too much money and it's
taking a toll on my
health and i'm not getting the work done
or the studying done that i want to do
i'm going to cut back on that then the
friendly thing to do is to say
yeah that's a good idea you should
curtail that maybe i'll actually join in
with you on that
um helping a friend quit smoking for
example would be something along those
lines
um it's something that's good for them
good in the sense of
of useful not not just in the sense of
pure utility but it's useful in the
sense that it's beneficial for them
then at a higher level we have what's
honorable and dishonorable
and for for aristotelian virtue ethics
this is something
very important and this is at a higher
level and again you can say well isn't
that purely subjective no for aristotle
it's not
there are certain guidelines for this he
provides you with these and in many of
his
his works you can you can read through
them
and you can agree or disagree with them
but before you worry about whether it's
subjective
read the aristotle so
this person is going to observe certain
certain limits
and they're going to observe these
limits both for themselves and for
others the others who they're involved
within social interaction
now let's look at one of the extremes so
the person who goes along with or
approves
everything whether it's right or wrong
they seem like they're actually friendly
that
that often is what trips people up
there's this sense that
if we're friends with somebody we should
love them
you know respect them hang out with them
no matter what that's what it means to
be friends or
or you know comrades or bros or pick
whatever you like you know
i mean side note i tend to think that
people use the word broader
are rather dull
and they often end up over here there's
something about
the culture of that but there's all
sorts of other things along those lines
too
if you get in with a bad group of people
who have bad
characters probably this is what they
want in a friend because they don't want
to be told
you're doing the wrong thing there's a
lot of people who cannot handle
criticism
uh in part because they are not actually
happy with who they are and sort of
things that they're doing because they
know in their heart that
what they're doing is is either wrong or
harmful or screwed up or
counterproductive
and they don't really want to hear that
they want to lose themselves in the
activities that they're doing and the
pleasures that they get from them
rather than developing morally so you're
not actually
helping somebody out by going along with
them doing wrong things
people like this are unwilling to stand
up to
other people and say no i'm not going to
go along with it what you're doing is
is actually bad or harmful or wrong
because they're
unwilling to give other people pain and
this could be that's where aristotle
stops we could do an analysis and go
much further
why are they unwilling to give other
people pain perhaps because of you know
traumatic childhood where when they gave
when they actually stood up to people
they were beaten down it could be a
desperate need to be liked by other
people
regardless of what your childhood is
like some people are just you know
desperately needy that way it could be
just a general lack of character
um there's quite a few people i think
who are are willing to go along
fairly easily with wrong things provided
that their group is doing it
provided that it's it's couched in the
wrong they're the right way
you know and they're not faced with uh
direct responsibility
themselves now somebody who goes along
with these sorts of things
aerosol has two different terms for this
he calls it obsequiousness
and flattering and why does he
make a distinction there it depends on
whether you're just doing this because
that's the way you are
and you're not getting anything out of
it in which case you're you're obsessed
or are you trying to get something out
of it are you kissing up
to somebody else and telling them that
they're a good person
you know like for example you belong to
the entourage of somebody who's a jerk
that you're a flatterer a colocase
a greek
term that was you know sort of universal
reprobation
call somebody that there are some people
who are just that way even if they don't
get anything out of it
oftentimes they get taken advantage of
themselves and that's being obsequious
that's
that's a certain lack of self-esteem
that's involved there
it takes self-esteem to actually be able
to tell other people no here's where the
limit is
you're crossing the line here now on the
other hand there's people who
have this this vice deficiency that he
calls
unfriendliness or quarrelsomeness and
they're sort of the mirror
opposite of this vice over here they
disapprove of
everything or most things even right
things
they are unwilling to give other people
pleasure they're unwilling to join in
they are the contrarians for
the sake of being contrarians these are
the people who are i
you know i have to admit that personally
i can't stand it when people say i just
want to play devil's advocate because
usually
you know what that means is i want to
indulge my my
vicious character of being a contrarian
and raising all sorts of problems just
for the sake of doing so
um sometimes you know you know there are
actual devil's advocates who would
belong over here but
more often over here
now why would a person have that sort of
character
in a way to give other people pleasure
to say that their
right is to you know
indulge them to engage them to withhold
that is to
in some respects feel like one has some
sort of power
over them it's a loser completely
illusory power it doesn't actually
contribute to anything
but i think that there are quite a few
people who do that
so we have one vice over here
deficiency people who are
too quick to judge too quick to say no
they do so on the wrong occasions
they draw lines too arbitrarily too
quickly
with the wrong people they disapprove of
even the
right things over here we have the
person who doesn't observe
limits other than to not have limits you
know these are the ones who will say
hey man you shouldn't judge
and which is a judgment right it's being
judgmental about other people
and that usually stems from a fear or
unwillingness to actually take
responsibility as a human being for
engaging in judgment and right here we
have the person who
is actually in the mean position who
has some standards who follows through
on those standards perhaps not
completely consistently depending on
what degree of virtue they develop
but actually is willing to say no to
some things
and to which frees you up by the way to
say
yes all the more exuberantly or
enthusiastically to the right things
and on that point i will end i just want
to
reiterate that one more time that's a
plagiarism there to say reiterate one
more time
by saying no to the wrong things by not
being this person
it frees you up to say yes
in a more intense more
enthusiastic more rewarding way
to the right things